stupid question yeah get another one
guild hey guys my name is jake i'm 26
and i live in st
louis right now i work in construction i
was a cook for nine years before this
almost everyone i work with including
the owner is pretty much openly racist i
can't stand it at all
they know i come from a family with a
mixed background but they still will say
the n-word around me as well
racial slurs it makes working very
difficult my issue is that i can't
afford to quit my job
i get decent pay and insurance which is
hard to come by i also want to be able
to afford rent in all
all my bills if i do quit should i leave
and get another job in the restaurant
industry which
might be [ __ ] uh might be [ __ ] or should
i stick with my current job until spring
or summer thank you guys
love you i would stay with the job and
then report
that the racism like anonymously yeah
not obviously yeah but
i mean but yeah who do you owe reported
to this isn't like they don't have hr in
a restaurant
or they don't yeah this isn't disney
well well then okay
well then i would um report it please
call the police
or you could you could go to you know i
mean the owners or whoever saying these
words
and go listen you know um thank you for
the job
i love working here but the n-word and
all the things that you're saying is so
offensive right and can you just cut it
out
say it
please film this and send it to us so i
can see how this goes no no just
this is what let me just let me just
because i haven't thought of through
play it out i haven't
the racist owner okay wait knock knock
knock jesus owner
uh hey [ __ ]
[Laughter]
close the door and walk away right and
i'd still be at the [ __ ] business at
work but then then you muster up
my head up just be like oh this is she's
not gonna change
[Laughter]
yeah but i love this job yeah i'll have
to absorb it i'll just absorb it
it'll turn into cancer 10 years from now
um yes you're right you're right you're
right
right you're right you're right all
right so i would go um i would quit and
get a new job or try it again one more
time
all right so knock knock knock what's up
power through um so um all right so um
that's why i came here actually um boss
[Laughter]
funny you say that one say that because
um but can you see me
[Laughter]
power through bobby power through power
through yeah because um
you know i know my um i'm slantier than
most but
i have perfect vision do you need me to
drive you home
that's just a stereotype any way could
you stop saying stuff like that
um why what's the problem because it
hurts my feelings
oh yeah why don't you just commit
suicide
like your brother
and then i would close the door i would
close the door and i would just stay
there i think yeah
very equal quietly oh these are very
quiet and stay there
because this is a boss you would bow on
your way out
i would you know i would bite my feet
and i would
walk out like that yeah oh my god
i love her he's done my podcast no i
know i saw him he uh do you know how he
got fired from doing that show
wow oh dude this is wild like i mean
it's
i'm going to get cancelled from this
yeah um yeah
um he was on a show called not american
gladiator can you look at a beastmaster
it's called oh netflix dude
this show's amazing it's called
beastmaster and it's like a bunch of
like people just